- Welcome everyone today at
the bit of an unusual location,
we are in London, as I
guess you can see here
based on the buses.
We are currently here on and
offsite with Building Radar.
Next to me as Leopold,
who is managing director
and founder of Building Radar.
he is also former school friend of mine,
worked at Google among
other companies before.
So looking forward now to
go actually to a WeWork
to meet a couple of other colleagues
from the Building Radar team.
We have a little team that
is based here in London.
I trust we are going to spend
a few very productive,
insightful days here.
And I will bring you along
of what is happening,
what we are doing.
So we are on our way to the WeWork,
actually love the city
because I spent one year here
at London School of
Economics, for a master.
And at the WeWork, our
chief product officer
was already waiting for us.
WeWorks are I think always
an interesting experience
some pros and cons of working
in a co-working space like that.
For our use case it definitely
was great to sit together
with some colleague of us.
We were one of the first people
here in the WeWork today.
At lunch, we went to Chinatown.
I always love the Chinatown in London,
this vibrant radiating atmosphere.
A good friend of us who
is also Chinese background
recommended us a really nice lunch place.
It was amazing food and
actually also quiet affordable
so definitely very much worth attending.
So afterwards we had some additional time
to explore the area.
My wife was actually with me as well,
together with our baby girl.
Actually later this year we
are expecting our second baby,
our second child, so exciting
times for us, for sure.
And afterwards we headed
back to the WeWork
to get some additional work done.
We were debating some new
features that we want to launch
for Building Radar platform,
realized that we all have
slightly different ideas
of how these were supposed to look like
so we figured let's just
take a sheet of paper,
let's just draw down
what we have in our minds
to then compare this.
Think this was quite
an effective exercise.
This time, We also moved
to slightly different area
of the WeWork which was
a little bit quieter.
We were a little bit more for ourselves.
And this led to, I think,
a quite productive session
with lots of ideation happening together
with our London-based colleagues.
Afterwards, we did something
that I missed quite a lot
and this is enjoying
the London pub culture.
So we met at one of the
traditional London pubs,
enjoyed a nice beer
and had just a very good time in general.
After that, of course,
we also visited LSE,
London School of Economics university,
where I did my master.
They did upgrade the university facilities
quite significantly since I was there.
Then the other day we went back there
just also to explore the campus by day.
Currently graduations were going on.
So congrats to everyone who
recently graduated from LSE.
I found the academic experience
to be reasonably challenging,
so this is definitely
very, very much deserved.
In the master program, I focused
on accounting and finance
and the knowledge that I acquired
during this year definitely helped me
on almost every single project afterwards
in consulting at McKinsey, so for me,
this experience was definitely worth it.
And also quite a lot of fun, indeed.
Afterwards, we were invited by
some friends who are working
as barristers in London to have lunch
at a very special location,
definitely enjoyed this one.
And then the next day, on the weekend
we went to some parks in London.
This is Piccadilly circus,
actually very close
to where the McKinsey office
at least used to be in London.
We had an amazing time.
There are some areas in
London where you feel like
you're actually not in London at all,
but that seemed to be more like Munich
or someplace like that.
So definitely enjoyed myself
also being there with my family.
And then afterwards we also
had the opportunity to visit
a good friend who lived
in the new Battersea
real estate development.
This is a very new real
estate development project
with some amazing living units
that are being created there.
Also completely different experience
compared to what you're
usually used to in London.
I hope you enjoyed these impressions.
Leave a like if you did.
Big, big thanks to all
the members as well.
My name is Heinrich,
releasing weekly content.
See you again next week.